le 21 juin prochain le prince williams
aura 18 ans il remercie par écrit les
médias pour lui avoir permis de vivre
discrètement dans son collège
la presse avait c'est vrai promis de
nous couvrir la vie privée du prince
qu'à partir de ses 18 ans en échange
buckingham palace offre des images
privées du jeune homme
que se passera-t-il après le 21 juin
seule la presse à scandale britannique
possède la réponse correspondance à
londres
pascal du cebr ce jeune homme est le
futur roi d'angleterre
il apprend la cuisine comme tous les
étudiants 10 tonnes l'école de la
noblesse britannique
c'est de la paella avec du poulet et du
riz
ces considérations culinaire ne sont ni
plus ni moins que sa première interview
télévisée
le king and palaces la même autorisé à
rire des bêtises de son meilleur ami
autorisé car il s'agit bien là d'image
officiels fournis gratuitement aux
médias par la couronne le prince joue
mal au football
le prince joue bien au water-polo et
satisfait pleinement ses professeurs on
est loin des séances photos royal
habituel une manière de satisfaire
l'appétit des journalistes et aussi de
les remercier
ils ont respecté le code de bonne
conduite établi à la mort de lady diana
et c'est ses enfants en paix jusqu'à
leur majorité
bien sûr quelques titres ont commis des
incartades mais globalement la presse
s'est bien tenue en revanche le 21 juin
le prince sera 18 ans la donne ne sera
plus la même
bien sûr le prince aura des petites
amies bien sûr nous devons respecter
salon privé mais l'une de ses petites
amies pourrait devenir la reine
d'angleterre
jamais la couronne n'avait eu à voir
tant de larmes au passage du cortège
royal alors fois de paradis le 21 juin
la chasse aux williams est ouverte